[Music]
you always said I'm probably not gonna
get married I definitely don't want kids
with your devotion to comedy do you
think a wife would have gotten in the
way of that would that have shifted your
focus to the point that you couldn't be
funny in a way I guess so but that's not
why I never got married
no it's funny as I listen to you you
know as we've repaired our relationship
yes one of the nice things about it is
I've been able to listen you also you're
in the car always now oh it's fantastic
and and you know I really enjoy it I'm a
fan thank you and I'm view and what I
find is that we're alike in so many ways
except that way right you know you asked
me if is it is it the career that would
hurt the marriage no it's not that it's
just that I never understood how I mean
I've tried to have relationships I've
been in love I've known some amazing
couple but I never understood how you
can be with the same person just day
after day week after week month after
month year after year I just don't get
my god I find it so I know you did
wonderful relax
right and that I don't feel that
pressure right and you know how weird it
is to bring somebody new into your life
I mean yes there's some keys to it yeah
seriously worried that like somebody
could like like you know go to the press
what about something happens and it you
know what I mean I mean yes you're not
an idiot and you're not gonna bring in
some you know some mania or so if you're
a nice person and treat people well
that's what's less of a concern most
people who get in trouble it's because
they do schmucky things and that's not
to say people can't take a shot at you
just because they see you're an easy
target people do that all the time and
I'm aware of that but you can't live
your life worrying about what bad [ __ ]
might happen that's true but you love
being alone you all you love it in other
words you wake up a morning you're happy
to be by yourself rekt and if something
funny hits you you can write it down you
can go to I like all my time to decide
what to do with all my time what's your
day today because I because I like your
schedule in my mind that you you you'll
do stand-up maybe on a weekend right
most comedians I speak to do not love
hitting a road oh no is it possible in
your career now at the point that you're
at because you're well-known on TV
you're famous
can you bomb on a given night no no I
bomb big is the people who come first of
all I'm doing this 40 years you can't
you don't bomb but the people who come
to see you are people who paid a hard
money ticket that's the only place I
work I get offered lots of things I
don't want to work corporate gigs why
because I'm not a corporate person I get
these calls and the money is outrageous
right
it's like triple what you'd normally
make in a night I don't care what the
money is that's another great thing
about being this age you cannot buy me
right time is so much more important
than money to me to get me to do
something you could offer me millions of
dollars to go to Dubai and do a show
know millions of dollars will not change
my life I'm a simple guy right I you
know people say how'd you get enough
money to buy into the Mets you have no
overhead
I said no wives no alimony no stupid
hobbies no no no car collect car
collecting those children no blame no
hookers no heroin no gambling I just
like what I like weed and people give me
weed I never have to buy weed you know I
went to the inauguration days of my life
I am entombed with that I was thinking
about you that day I was watching you
more than I was watching me romp first
of all I don't even know how you get
past you've got three million more votes
than I got it right in my mind you won
the election the electoral college I
can't explain that I don't under more
who felt it was his rights we're gonna
be denied but the majority of the people
in the country voted for you you got the
job done great when you stand in there
watching this guy uh what the hell is
going through your head are you just I
would imagine you were on
antidepressants that day you know how
here's how I felt about it I mean
obviously I was crushed I was
disappointed and I was really surprised
because I couldn't
figure out what had happened and you
hadn't even written a losing speech when
you lost that yeah you ain't only
Victorino and and every everything was
pointed in that direction so when he's
going to be inaugurated I was going as a
former first lady right that was the
reason I was there I was no longer in
the Senate I was a secretaries of state
don't usually attend so I was what your
sense of duty is my husband was
president I was first lady and this is
what we say to the country there's
continuity that is exactly how I felt
and a lot of people said to me don't put
yourself through that don't go and I
said look I ran for president because I
love this country
I wanted to serve this country I thought
I would have been a really good
president I want he would have been
spectacular with all your experience
yeah
I hope our own affairs yep but I'd be
crushing NATO right now I don't think so
yeah we need them but are you standing
up so I said to myself I said to
everybody who talked to me about it look
I hope he's gonna be a better president
then I think he will be I'm worried
about it but I'm gonna do everything I
can as I told him when I called him you
know that terrible night I'm sad how I
did I said you know I said look you know
Donald I want you to be a good president
I will do whatever I can to help you so
you know we're in this generation or was
he a sort so shocked he couldn't he was
shocked right and so when I got there
you know go ahead get out there you put
on the best face possible and I'm you
know bill and I are sitting with George
and Laura Bush and then he started on
that speech which was so bizarre and
that's when I got really worried I
thought wait a minute it wasn't rational
it's not rational but it's also not it's
not politics it's not what a president
does a president is supposed to try to
reach out to people who weren't for him
or her you're supposed to say okay I'm
gonna be the president of everyone those
who supported me and those who didn't
because we're gonna pull the country
together I'd hope that I would hear a
little of that I didn't hear any of that
and then that carnage in the street and
the dark dust
be in vision I was sitting there like
just wow couldn't believe in george w
bush says to me well that was some weird
[ __ ]
is anyone officially welcome over Los
Angeles oh that's your I'm gonna do that
do alright yeah I officially welcome you
to Los Angeles that the paradise of the
world you love you love Ellie because
Jimmy you didn't welcome him you're
gonna do it you're gonna do with a new
show I will welcome I'm on the show yeah
meanwhile it's so silly I mean welcome
me to LA when you think about it I mean
Tom why Philly because I could do the
same show in New York you know what I'm
saying it doesn't matter
but he'll great to have you here and I'm
ecstatic when I heard that you're coming
to LA I said it myself I want to be in
this show when he comes to LA they're so
fantastic you are the greatest guy to do
this for me seriously I'm being rich
Jimmy - I mean the fact that you guys
would even care to get up this early and
come over here are you kidding me
I mean I mean we love you Howard you do
are you kidding me now every single time
I've done an interview with you vo it's
a great time and the reaction of the
people after which was always fantastic
why because you are great [ __ ]
interviewer thank you mean you're just a
natural you don't you know write down
the questions and you kind of come up
like a program
tell me now when did you start working
out okay what was it like when you grew
up with your father I heard he was very
disciplinary this is a [ __ ] but so
you you you kind of developed like this
these last hours I've been driving in
here from Santa Monica and I've been
listening to you guys today it is such a
pleasure to listen to you guys talk
because it's a natural talk that guys do
where they hang out in the gym or at
home or when you smoke a stogie or
something like that right play chess
that's how you talk you playing chess
these days yeah I want to play with you
I mean you'll kick my ass but I want a
hug I'm not that good I'm just I just
love play I said about you in the book
and I really do believe this about you
governor that the the fact is the way I
relate to you is we both had this insane
drive to be known to the world I really
do feel that I was on a mission
somehow stand out to be seen and I feel
both of us really had that need inside
of us to be seen am i accurate about
that you're absolutely correct the thing
that we both have I think the old three
can say that that we have the same drive
you know do not not like the two of you
but yeah I'd you know come on are we I'm
driven you're absolutely right I mean we
know it's just you and I know what are
we we just like to shoot for the top did
we mean I mean one of my rules to
success when I give seminars and
lectures about the inner motivational
speeches and stuff like that is shoot
for the top don't go and shoot for
something little this is where I always
said when I was getting into acting I
did not want to be an actor I wanted to
be a leading man I wanted to be the
highest paid entertainer I wanted to be
above the title that's what I was
shooting for why should for something
little right when in bodybuilding I
didn't want to be mr. universe I want to
be the greatest bodybuilder of all time
you've been a victim of and almost a
victim of the casting couch you said at
one point in your career you were very I
don't know where you were at in your
career some producer invited you to very
it was my first audition ever Oh Mike I
had never I was I had just turned 19 I
might have still been 18 I had never
been on out for an audition I asked this
modeling agent if she heard of anything
like I was going to give this acting
thing a try she said yep go to this
guy's house it's on Saturday at 9:00 so
a few all of your auditions are done at
the p.m. oh my god Oh II this is holiday
yeah there should be a law against that
right I mean but but you would think
your agent or somebody but I didn't have
an agent but you think somebody would
have thought she had a clue either I
guess this is what they do and the guys
a big deal and he's famous it was a very
big deal and it is still a big deal
so on a Saturday night at nine o'clock
you go over to audition for a film yeah
and and and how does that play out what
happened I knocked on the door and he
opened up the door and he was in his
pajamas are you barefoot first of all
why do guys think they're gonna like
like why do you guys think a showing
your dick to someone it's gonna turn
it's embarrassing when any guy thinks
they're sexy he had all sexy guys I
should not act as though they are
physical being is in any way tempting
that can't be a good look on any love
and by the way I just like want it clear
I mean I don't know Robin do you agree
like we don't want to see you just pull
out your day no that's exactly right
so you go to the guy's house yeah it's
Saturday night and I'm sure your and
here he answers the door in the pajamas
do you see ya turn around and say I
should have I didn't pajamas and a good
look on a man no no and but he was he
had a very healthy ego he felt very good
about himself there was some kind of
music playing in the house music never
good cold marble and crystal and then we
sat down and we started talking he said
very close to me that was strange
the drinking bothered me I was like this
is doesn't feel right I kept kind of
saying as he was asking me questions
about me I said I've never done this so
just tell me like I have these pages do
you want me to read these pages and he
was like no no no no no this is I'm just
gonna we're just gonna talk and then at
one point he put his hand on my knee and
that's when I just went ooh and I just
it's crazy and girls talk about this
where you just go blank like you don't
know what to do but I left I don't even
know how I got out of the house but I
left and I that's amazing driving my
yeah cuz it would have ended really
badly but I was driving my Ford Fiesta
that I was renting like up Laurel Canyon
and I was so angry with myself that I
didn't say something and I was like why
I'm not that kind of girl like why did I
not tell him to go [ __ ] himself like it
made me so angry you know why because in
the moment if you're a decent human
being even you
believe what's happening to you yeah and
you feel like you should be polite yeah
it's weird and then afterwards you go
why am I so [ __ ] polite exactly why
am i such a good boy or good girl like
while you're looking people get like
murdered because they're polite there's
like there's like books about how like
most people would rather not be impolite
and and keep themselves out of mortal
danger right then potentially like hurt
someone else's feelings yeah which is
crazy it took me eight years for this
thing to come full circle because he
offered me a job oh and I'm I went
purely just to have my moment where he
said nice to meet you and I said no
we've met before he had no recollection
of it and his producing partner was
standing right next to him and he was
embarrassed
which by the way it shows you how many
women he did it to he doesn't remember
like it was not a one-off that's insane
that is insane the amount they numbers
so you mean literally he ate now you're
famous yeah had no idea I get Charlize
Theron in a movie yeah you walk in and
you finally said no you met me and
here's what happens and I went down the
list I said it was at 9 p.m. on a
Saturday at your house you were wearing
pajamas I went down the law had my
moment what did you say he said wow I do
not remember that yeah I bet you he does
I don't remember that conveniently I
forgot oh my god when you just guest
hosted on Saturday Night Live yeah
[ __ ] killed it right you elevated
that show I said this on the excellent
yeah thank you a couple of things stuck
out you did the song about Chris Farley
yes which brought the place down brought
a tear to everyone's eye was it was it
was poignant in the way that like it's
like a Bruce Springsteen song is like a
mage's various the guy made you think
right right right
you did the monologue and you sang to
about getting fired yeah oh yeah talk to
me about that yes
don't you think psychologically because
I was watching this thing thinking
Sandler finally had his day because
Lauren fired you in some mysterious
[ __ ] way and suddenly you come back
to guest house after saying no for all
those years you kill it
you're probably the back of mine saying
still [ __ ] you I look at this crap the
mic there yeah I gotta be honest I
didn't have any I think I might have
been like that 15 years ago right if I
came on and did well and like yeah I'm
I'm [ __ ] old enough now I realize
what Saturday Night Live did for me and
put the 5 let's turn that down played
but at the time I was hurt because I was
I didn't know what else I was gonna do
and I know it wasn't
Lorne decision the NBC had dude I know
he didn't like our gang I mean Farley
and they had a winning cast there and
you had been there for five years you
probably have stayed one or two at least
maybe more maybe I would have never left
because well I'm not good at saying
goodbye but seriously you had to get rid
of me Sam when they fired you it really
caught you by surprise put a lump in my
throat only again everyone turned out
great we don't write the ending of the
story but at the time you were livid I
was probably sad into covering the
sadness up with being mad and saying
yeah [ __ ] you above but I remember when
I saw Farley and he said me too
they don't want me we were both like
[ __ ] this [ __ ] we would got mad together
pretended pretended we weren't sad and
pretended this was for the best but but
move far I want to know this what fired
me this is how I got fired I my manager
sandy he was talking to me and I said
yeah next year on the show bubble bond
he was like maybe you know go back next
year and I was like I don't know man I
still got a few more things like
and I was like yeah think about it he's
like I think you thought about it
thinking you need because you're a
leading lady people are constantly
probably telling you what to do and what
not to do to not affect your career
people say don't be photographed with a
girlfriend
I used to have conversations where
people would be like if you don't want
to talk about it and you don't want to
define yourself then you need to stop
setting yourself up for that by going
out and whatever and it was just like
well here's the thing now that question
is it's a ridiculous and ignorant
question and it's a sort of like violent
yes like okay a friend of mine has a kid
and she was like hey I asked my kid if
he was like Gabe it was like in like the
nicest like sort of most I was just
curious I just want to know him I just
want to be as close to him as I possibly
can and he's really young and he is
really self possessed and very clearly
already feels comfortable in a way that
feels fluid and cool and kind of like
you don't know where it's gonna go and
he was like this is child abuse and I
was like it's true it's like you know on
some level of the the sort of fervent
question that was demanded of me for so
long is now ridiculous that's true it's
it's a non-starter but that's a
Hollywood thing I remember the days yeah
Rock Hudson was a gay man there's a
couple of guys in Hollywood who are
leading men who were gay but if the
Pajero public found out you were [ __ ]
right no one could accept you in a
heterosexual role like you're an actor
you're pretending to be something what's
the difference but yet society hadn't
gotten there I am so coincidentally
lucky it to be like living in in this
time and I look at literally just like
kids people five years younger than me
have it so much easier than I did three
years ago like it was just like it was
just this ridiculous no reason why
anyone needs to like provide an easy
narrative for other people to digest
it's like there's no why why would I
simplify something very complex just in
order for you to feel comfy it's like
nah I don't want to diminish this like
cool thing which is like discovering
yourself and your sexuality and like how
that change is like yeah
why that yeah I actually really do
admire your courage
because I'm old enough to remember how
horrible it was when people would come
out and especially in Hollywood oh man
and I wait the way you live in your life
is a beautiful example you were like hey
[ __ ] it I coming off Twilight I can I
can do movies I can do this but I'm not
gonna sit I would enjoy holding the
person I loves hand in public yes you're
Iron Man portrayal has become the thing
it is a huge moneymaker yeah you still
enjoy doing it yes I'll tell you the
truth I didn't expect it to become what
it became and it is this very large
multi-headed Hydra at this point and I
also I've always had other interests and
according to Scorsese it's not cinema I
gotta take a look at that you know what
why did he say that because it's his
opinion and what it is venom but isn't
it I mean it plays in theaters yeah well
what did he mean by that that it's not
cinema I appreciate his opinion because
I think it's like it's like anything we
need all of the different perspectives
so we can come to Center and move on you
know come up I know you've been to a two
magnanimously yeah don't really what
were you insulted when he said that it's
not cinema that somehow Iron Man isn't
cinema it is cinema to me well I mean
look it'd be like saying Howard Stern is
in radio it is it is it makes no sense
what we see jealous of the success it's
not but I mean he's Martin Scorsese then
what did he mean by it I think he in his
view and by the way there's a lot to be
said for how these genre movies and I
was happy to be part of the problem if
there is one right you know were
denigrated the the the art the era the
art form of cinema and by the way when
you come in like a stomping beast and
you eliminate the competition in such a
demonstrative way the you know it's it's
phenomenal it is phenomenal and maybe
he's upset about the
you know what it is you get older you're
used to cinema being a certain way can I
tell you something yeah do you actually
think Martin Scorsese is upset about
Marvel movies yes yes I do because he's
the guy who's busy archiving films and
he has my dad's films and I appreciate
his point of view Robin what do you
think yeah and why not I don't know it's
kind of a knock I mean the fact is I
don't were you ever nominated for
Academy Award for iron man now don't you
think that's a and be serious yeah
because it's a superhero movie they they
turn their nose that the performance is
excellent well it's a totally believable
character well I'm so glad you brought
this up because there was some talk
about it and I said let's let's not and
because I'm much more like you than you
might really want to to believe I listen
to the show I agree with most all of
your opinions varied though they may be
occasionally you'll go on some on some
you know tributary trail of thought that
I got like god that's not how I see it
but I go but I'd love that you see it
that way
didn't Paul McCartney explain a
collusion and the mullah report to John
Lennon well this I do for myself I
really feel like where we are in our
lives sort of wisdom and appreciation I
want John and Paul to talk to each other
yes I don't care how and then it became
a time machine where you know cuz John
left us in 1980 so then and now I lately
I've been doing Paul McCartney
explaining the Lennon so what's going on
down there pole Oh big whoop to do with
the Orangemen the big orange man hosts
the orange man you know chumpy the
president I told you burn he's a big
orange man he's got little white circles
around his eyes he's got like cotton
candy hair that swirls about you know I
said maybe using Koontz with the
Russians in cahoots yeah you know I'd do
anything that would be do so they hired
this man named EULA you know he's a very
you know he's a different looking
gentleman's really narrow in the top of
this head you know and his cheeks go out
like a big chipmunk you know and they
gave him like 25 million quid
you know to investigate you know he went
through a million bases of paper and all
these interviews and he said you know I
guess he's not in goods couldn't believe
it sounds very strange and then there
was Hillary's emails you know they
didn't know what to do
what's an email John the Cavanaugh
hearings when everybody was so flipped
out it just occurred to me that if Paul
McCartney read the news he'd still get
the news but it wouldn't be depressing
because it would be guys it'd be like
you know what are they trying to do
we're trying to get a top judge a man
John you know judge a man
silly girl this girl this guy Kavanagh
seems like a nice nice enough bloke you
know maybe a bit of a sudden like you
know what do you mean we like beer too
you know
and so they said alright you could be
the top Georgia man and then a bird from
California says hold on hold on t no
doobly doo bee doo doo bee on me you
know it just makes it lighter you can
throw me a news story doesn't understand
the college cheating scandal at all
can't figure that want to know what's
happened what happened down there
[Laughter]
you know and they said I gotta get me
kid in the top top typically top of
school you know and they gave all this
money it was not enough I said what if
we say they're rose rose
they're like rose and college what is
really enough to do with college that
lets you in the college girls you know
they they put them on little little
playful rowers you have in a room little
like you exercise Rosie they took
pictures and the father gave a half
million dollars they said could to go to
college but they didn't even want to go
why would they put them in there if they
didn't want to go Instagram what
Instagram
that's something Keith Moon used to snot
in celebration of my new book that will
be out on May 14th which is what Tuesday
you're gonna
my favorite interview of all time do you
love all the interviews right yeah I
want to make that clear yeah how should
I do this Robin should I just announce
that the person is on mic right now I
announce him or should I tell you why or
how do you want to do this I think I
want to know why okay I went home after
the interview and I said this is the
first time in my life I feel like I
asked every question I needed to ask I
feel like I had one of the most sincere
conversations and it was so fulfilling
it was funny it was brilliant in terms
of what the guest was saying there were
moments that I picked up on things in
this and then we talked about a variety
of topics you felt complete complete was
a complete conversation you couldn't
have done it any better this guest has a
TV show I'll tell you that right now
this guest and his TV show he can't
reveal I feel all sides of him and I
don't think people even understand how
super funny he is and how insightful and
how bright and we got to know that and I
even thought in my own delusion I
thought afterwards oh my god this guest
and I we're gonna become like really
good friends he's like my brother he's
like my brother like he's the brother
I'd would want and that person is huh
mr. Conan O'Brien
Conan are you there yes I'm here Howard
you know Conan I always thought that
because I just want to stay on this a
little bit about picking you as the
favorite interview of all time it was
very good to miss I think it's a mistake
no I just we're gonna be really honest
with you I think you had Paul McCartney
Billy Joel I think I think you're gonna
regret this
don't you admit that sometimes you have
a guest you vibe with that person and
you think maybe you don't experience
this but but you think oh my goodness we
just had this incredible connection and
we'll probably end up calling one
another but there's really no facility
for that like when you're 11 yes yes
yeah I feel like I know what you're
talking about
I should call Conan and somehow have a
relationship with him but you don't you
never do that right you know I don't but
I know exactly what you're talking about
for example when you and I had that
interview I left and this is like two
people that
you know it's like we had sex Brian we
and and in a lot of ways I think we did
and that day I agree and we stumbled we
stumbled away from each other and what
happened was I felt wow I think that was
really good I really liked that
interview that was I really felt like I
connected with Howard and then I was in
New York and I was walking around and
people were coming up to me on the
street and telling me how much that
meant to them and I thought what are you
talking about
I mean we just I just you know I killed
an hour with Howard we had a good time
it felt good but I never stopped hearing
about that interview and I've been loath
to talk to you since because I thought
we're never gonna we're never gonna
match that so I should just get out of
the business well that's always what
I've been but Laurie been trying to do
[Music]
the Howard Stern Show